i'm telling you that i'm going to rehab
okay i have to go to rehab so what i
would you don't think you need
rehab if you think you can pull a prank
on kris
jenner and get away with it think again
and when that happens it's like
it's magical in a sneak peek at
thursday's episode of keeping up with
the kardashians
the famous momager flips the script and
gets kim
good like how did this become a thing
just a little refresher
last week chloe and scott disick played
the ultimate prank on chris
i'm thinking i dress up like her and we
have a paparazzi
take photos of me yes that's the money
yeah
chloe and kim got their mama wasted i
have the bartender giving mom
her dirty martinis and i have my water
martinis then coco transformed into
chris with the help of a glam squad
it was definitely a process and she and
scott did a whole freaking photo shoot
to capture some seemingly
unflattering pics of the family's famous
matriarch
i feel like i'm spielberg out there
shooting this i mean i'm killing it
yeah like chloe got in a dumpster people
that's commitment anyway since chris was
drunk at dinner and the night was a bit
hazy
and they got her longtime boyfriend
corey gamble in on the joke
they were able to convince her with the
help of the family's publicist
that she really did pee outside of a
liquor store and that a media outlet was
going to publish the pics
they have images of you from monday
night
that's when scott and chloe came clean
and revealed the truth
wow i honestly don't like you guys
now flash forward to tonight's episode
chris wants to keep that prank going
since
kim doesn't know that she knows what we
could do
if we really want to get her is caller
in paris and say that i
made a reservation at palm springs stop
it okay let's call kim
hello hi so i just wanted to tell you
i had matthew call around to a couple
different like
okay i'm telling you that i'm going to
rehab
okay i have to go to rehab yeah
game freaking on you don't think you
need
rehab kim i blacked out and climbed into
a trash bin
how chris was able to get through that
without laughing i mean
well done chris well done
kim i blacked out and climbed into a
trash bin
kim was clearly buying what chris was
selling because she
immediately texted her fam you guys mom
called me
she's checking herself into rehab i feel
bad she's having sleepless nights over
this should we tell her
no we're keeping this going
kim was like seriously stressed af
naturally the mark of a successful prank
it's really stressful i like literally
have anxiety
i don't know what to do chloe wants to
keep this prank going
and i just feel so bad because it's now
getting me
i don't know how i even got roped into
this this was not my prank
but if they want to keep it going i'm
not going to ruin it for them
but like my mom can't go to rehab we're
not going to let her go to rehab
of course the new season of keeping up
premiered shortly after the family
announced that the reality show is
ending after its 20th season
in early 2021. we had fun but a source
previously told et
they aren't ruling out the idea of doing
other shows in the future let's just
tune
in because you never know what's going
to happen and when e.t caught up with
keeping up executive producer ryan
seacrest
earlier this month he dished on the
family's choice to say goodbye
at some point you're gonna say you know
we did it we had a great run
we're gonna live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it
you